[Music]
I'm Laura Ingram and this is the Ingram
angle from Washington tonight
America overrun that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
for the past two years while the regime
media has been obsessed with all things
Trump January 6. of course the drag
queen shows America was being invaded by
millions along our Southern border
now for a sense of how the regime media
are covering this unparalleled border
surge look no further than this headline
from axios
Biden braces for potentially 14 000
migrants a day well instead of braces
For It should read roots for
look they came from dozens of countries
and among them were sex traffickers
cartel Hitmen child molesters and even
some who are convicted murderers and
when Biden was inaugurated drunk kid
pings they knew that they were going to
become even richer by forcing migrants
to go through them for safe passage into
the United States
but all along not only did the Biden
Administration not repel The Invasion it
encouraged it
this was a purposeful willful wanton
intentional effort to overwhelm our
border patrol and flood our beautiful
country with millions of illegals
now 95 or more have no legitimate Asylum
claims but they do have scripts that
they memorize mouthing just enough for
the right words to allow them to be
immediately released and bust to
wherever they want to go
but every once in a while they let the
truth slip out
would you have tried to do this when
Donald Trump was President definitely
not
definitely we have the chance so did you
come here because Joe Biden was elected
president basically
basically
the refusal of the Biden Administration
to use its authority to stop this
invasion is the most egregious abuse of
power any of us have seen in our
lifetimes
now Biden held on to his emergency covet
Authority remember until the spring of
2023 at least probably continue after
that yet apparently that emergency isn't
bad enough to keep title 42 in place
which allows for immediate border
turnbacks during a Health crisis
that expires next week so the only
conclusion any of us can draw is that
the Democrats want a different America
they can't rely on elections to
necessarily Advance us toward a global
government and zero carbon output so
they need new voters voters who are
ignorant of the American tradition and
whose children will not be taught about
it in our Public Schools
now it doesn't matter who these new
people are what their intentions are
whether they'll be drains on our schools
our health care System whether they're
criminals
as long as they're not you whom the left
hates intensely
now the Biden folks are so Brazen that
their response to the Border catastrophe
is to make the Trek easier for the
migrants
why allow them to walk when we can fly
them into the United States
so the white Administration is
considering expanding not shrinking
Asylum categories to include Cubans
Haitians and nicaraguans
and they'll allow them to be flown into
the country after merely applying for
Asylum abroad
the daughtering Biden has never been to
the Border we've known that a total
dereliction of Duty it's a health
economic and National Security crisis
that's unfolding right at this moment
whatever happens to Americans because of
this
they think it's just all necessary
collateral damage you're not their
priority
families are suffering American families
like this my son was standing on the
driveway when this gang member came from
behind it was going to shoot his friend
in the back and got my son in the arm
and he literally blefted that he died in
surgery our kids have been dead for
years and years and we can't even get
them to even say anything nice about it
they ignore us after the incalculable
damage Biden has done to America just at
the border alone
one thing is certain
they'll only change course if they
believe it's going to hurt them
politically
that's why it's so critical for
Republicans to stay 100 unified here on
the side of Law and Order controlling
our borders
now Shimmer and Biden would love to say
that they've struck some kind of deal
with someone like a I don't know Tom
Tillis of North Carolina or Susan
Collins from Maine on the immigration
issue and then they like to rope House
Republicans in too so they can hold a
big bipartisan signing ceremony at the
White House just like they did with
their so-called Marriage Act yesterday
but California governor Gavin Newsom of
all people with his own White House
Ambitions I think he sees political
trouble ahead for the Democrats
and what the world looks like free
title 42 and what it likely is going to
look like in a few weeks
and then he told an ABC affiliate quote
the fact is what we have now is not
working and it's about to break I say
this not to point fingers he said but as
a father and as someone who feels
responsible to be part of the solution
now millions of American Patriots over
the almost now 250 years have sacrificed
so that we'd remain a free and
independent nation
one where we control our own destiny
one where government represents what's
Best in our interests for us
but now for almost two years
we've had a government whose main goal
is to get you used to a lower standard
of living and a new normal
yeah that new normal requires you to
suspend your own dreams and beliefs for
a nightmare that will never end
so it's going to be up to us to awaken
those who are still asleep out there and
mobilize for the next election against
anyone of any party who facilitated this
Invasion and that's the angle hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else